[موسيقى]
موجز الاخبار من الجزيره السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله قالت الاذاعه الاسرائيليه ان
الجيش اغلقه وعزل منزل الشهيد خيري علقم
منافذ عمليه القدس التي اسفرت عن مقتل
سبعه مستوطنين واصابه اخرين بجروح و
تداولته وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه صورا
لافراد من الجيش يستخدمون ادوات اللحام
لاغلاق المنزل تاتي هذه الخطوه بعد ساعات
قليله من قرار المجلس الوزلي المصغر اجازه
اغلاق منزلي خير علقم وذلك في اقرب وقت
ممكن
اذا الطاقم الوزاريه الاسرائيلي والمصغروا
كما قد اتخذ قرارات عقابيه ردا على عمليتي
القصه تضمنت حرمان عائلتي منفذيه العمليات
من الحق في التامين الوطني ومزايا اخرى
ورفض منح بطاقات الهويه الخاصه بسكان
القدس لعائلات منافذيه العمليات كما قرر
المجلس الامني المصغر والتسريعه وتوسيع
نطاق منحي تراخيص الاسلحه الناريه
الاسرائيليين
وتعزيز الاجراءات الامنيه في المستوطنه
قتل حراس مستوطنه كيدوم شرق مدينه قلقيليه
في شمال الضفه الغربيه شابا فلسطينيا بزعم
محاولته تنفيذ عمليه اطلاق نار وعقل متحدث
باسم جيش الاحتلال ان الشاب الفلسطيني كان
يحمل مسدسا وان حراس المستوطنه رصده
واشتبه بانه يتهيا لسن هجوم واطلقوا
الرصاصه عليها
في ردود الفعل الفلسطيني حملت حركته فتح
الحكومه الاسرائيليه النتائج المترتبه على
سياستها التي وصفتها بالفارسيه وقال
المتحدث باسم حركه فتحنا حكومه الاحتلال
المتعاقبه اغلقت كل الابواب وتركت باب
المواجهه والقتل والاعتقالات اضافه الى
انتهاك المقدسات من جانبه دعى رئيس
المركبه السياسي لحركه حماس اسماعيل هنيه
قاده العالم والشعوب الحره التدخل الوقت
في جرائم فير وما وصفها بحكومه اليمين
الفاشيه واضاف هنيه ان المنطقه متوجهه الى
الصعيد
لم تبقى داخل السجون من جهتها قالت حركه
الجهاد الاسلامي ان عمليه القدس ضربتا
المنظومه الامنيه والعسكريه الاسرائيليه
وبين ما تتجه الانظار الى زياره المرتقبه
لوزير الخارجيه الامريكيه الى المنطقه قال
جول روبن ان مساله العنف ستكون على راس
مباحثات بلنكن خلال زيارته التي تشمل تل
ابيب ورام الله والقاهره من جهته يواصل
مدير الاستخبارات المركزيه الامريكيه
ويليامبرز اتصالاته ضمن جوله تتضمن
محادثات مع مسؤولين اسرائيليين قبل
الانتقال الى رام الله للقاء قياده سياسيه
وامنيه فلسطينيه
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الايرانيه يحبطه هجوم
بثلاثه طائرات مسيره صغيره استهدفت احد
المصانع العسكريه التابعه لها بمحافظه
اصفهان وسط البلاد واقله الوزاره من
المضادات الدفاعيه تصدت للمسيرات ما ادى
الى انفجار اثنتين منها وان الاضرار
اقتصرت على سقف المصنع دون الاضرار
بالمعدل
اينما كنت مقابل توقعاتكم بكل خير
[موسيقى]